well as europe the uk and the us race to
vaccinate their populations against
covet 19.
africa has so far secured only one-fifth
of the vaccination doses
that the continent needs the african
union says it has secured
270 million covid19
vaccine doses which will be made
available this year
now this will supplement the 600 million
doses obtained by the who's
kovacs alliance for africa but some
african nations they
aren't willing to wait guinea for
example is now
testing the russian vaccine sputnik v
and has ordered two million doses
south africa has ordered 20 million
doses of the astrazeneca vaccine
and kenya has ordered 24 which should
start arriving by the end of next month
now that's not soon enough for many
health coworkers though who feel that
they have been
exploited they've gone on strike to
demand better pay
medical cover and adequate protective
gear
the government is playing down their
concerns and threatening to
fire those who strike as dw's mario
muller reports
from nairobi
dorcas mugore loves her job as clinical
officer
a big part of it though was to work
closely with covet 19 patients
then one day she got sick herself i
survived covered i went through a lot of
problems after i was infected i didn't
have a medical cover which could cover
my bills and i got so sick
i was supposed to go on oxygen my both
of my sons were infected too
it was very traumatizing she survived
nine of her colleagues did not and then
another shock
she had to pay the expense of hospital
bill from her own pocket
for over a month now she's been on
strike with her nurses and medical lab
officers
more than 30 000 healthcare workers
according to the unions
their demands include protective gear
health insurance and compensation
for families in case of death if any of
us
is to die from coronavirus today
their family is going to live in
destitution
and as if that is not enough then they
tell you if you do not go back to that
unsafe working environment
we are going to suck you indeed
healthcare workers across kenya have
lost their jobs for participating
in strikes the government says are
illegal we put the health care workers
demands to the cabinet secretary of
health
muttai kagwe we have more than enough
ppe's in this country
since october of this year we have got
the most generous
insurance package that has ever been
given to the civil servants
they do have some legitimate issues that
they have raised with us for example
delays in their payments and so on
the reason for those delays says the
health minister is the current economic
situation
nobody is denying that you should be
getting your money you should
it's a legitimate right but we are also
saying
that when there is this situation in the
country
let's also face it together you know and
don't make it look like you're
blackmailing the government
at his weakest point as dawkers doesn't
feel protected by her employer she's
awaiting the covet 19 vaccine
kenya expects to receive the vaccine
through the kovacs facility
among other sources but experts say a 60
vaccination target is needed to achieve
herd immunity on the african continent
meanwhile wealthy nations have reserved
more than half of the vaccines
even though they're home to only 14
percent of the world's population
so there's kind of some selfishness to
say let us fast reserve
enough for our people i think the issue
here is
that global responsibility issue so you
can reserve as many as you want for your
country
but what is your responsibility to
ensuring the world is safe
to be safe that's also doka's wish for
herself and her colleagues
how do you feel about that that can you
and other african countries get the
vaccination later
yeah we feel like we are less human
we feel like we are not considered but
anyway better let than never at least we
are hopeful we are going to get the
vaccination
kenya's first tranche of 24 million
vaccine doses is expected to arrive next
month
talkers now hopes the vaccine will
finally ensure her safety
and for more on this let's bring in now
dr moga kamayani she is a global health
expert and joins us from the uk welcome
to the program and thank you for being
with us
we understand you've been campaigning
for a more equitable distribution
of covet vaccines among rich and poorer
countries
how do you think it can be achieved
it can be achieved by increasing the
supply
of the vaccine by maximizing production
which means that
companies and research institutions
share their technology
and intellectual property so other
potential producers in developing
countries and in other countries
can produce more doses and we
and we should be fair allocation of the
doses
so it's not everything in in rich
countries
but you know as your report says health
workers all over the world
should be vaccinated at the same time
this is a priority group according to wh
okay so um that's the solution as you
see it um
i'd like to ask you also about the
current state of affairs because we have
the who
chief has just been speaking he said
that the world
is on the brink of a catastroph
catastrophic
moral failure how dangerous do you see
vaccination nationalism right now and
and just
what you're seeing transpire around the
world
well it is dangerous because on public
health grounds
you can't really keep the virus at your
borders
and we're seeing mutations already so
you
keep the virus um you know outside and
countries with the other countries
without vaccination it means we'll have
more mutations that
might not be susceptible to the vaccine
so
it will it will ruin that the impact of
vaccinating your
your own people or you know or not you
know the countries that are doing that
so on public health grounds it's very
dangerous
on economic grounds you know who you
can't revive your economy we're
interconnected globally and therefore
you know who you're going to trade with
who you're going
which tourists will come or which
business people will come to your
country
when there's no vaccination in that
country so it's very difficult
from economic bases and also it's
morally wrong it's morally wrong
um and and it's it's also i mean we have
to mention
and and um you know just make the
observation that despite
massive resources massive money in in
countries for example here in europe
where we are currently right now
um you know the continent is still being
ravaged by this pandemic
just um you know tell us about the
situation elsewhere in other countries
that
might not have those resources
well as you know the the the virus has
been going like in
in in waves so for the first wave
the the infection rate in africa wasn't
as big let's say as in europe it was the
second wave now
infection infections is very high in
all countries it's much higher than the
first wave in
every every continent so in africa it's
also getting high
in in in latin america of course it's
very very
high uh infection you know brazil comes
immediately after the us
in terms of the number of infections so
it's very serious
everywhere it's not sparing anybody
really it's not sparing any country
so we so we need a mechanism to
maximize supply maximize fair
distribution
fair allocation basically to all
countries vaccinating the
at risk groups are priority groups you
know health workers all
people other groups until you end up
vaccinating
everybody or at least vaccinating the
majority of the population to achieve
herd community
health immunity and and therefore really
control the virus without herd
immunity globally we can't control the
virus
dr mogul kamagani a global health expert
thank you so much for joining us to
share that insight
thank you